i do want to talk about isaac for a
minute you gave
birth uh last january right before we
went into lockdown which is kind of
crazy when you think about it what has
motherhood
been like i mean being in a pandemic for
almost the majority of it
you know having giving birth in january
and then going to the lockdown in march
i got an extended maternity leave that i
never
thought that i would get that was really
the silver lining in all of it and i
had eight months straight with him that
me and justin actually got to spend with
him so that was so beautiful
being a parent a lot of it is trial and
error and asking for help
and figuring out along the way and just
having the confidence in yourself that
mom and dad know best what's for the
baby um
and and forgiving yourself along the way
is isaac talking yet oh
yes he is a little chatterbox
yes it's so funny he does this really
funny thing with his lip when he lips
when he says mama and he's like
[Music]
and dada is his favorite word
and you know i've totally i'm okay with
it
it just is what it is um and now the new
word is dog
everything is dog i'm even dog sometimes
it's like dog
dog dog do you guys have a dog
or he just wants no we won't have a dog
for his birthday someone sent a balloon
of a dog and now he's upset so now i'm
like god now we have to get a dog
that's so funny that's precious how how
do you feel like
motherhood i guess has changed you
if at all well
i think in some ways it's made me really
kind of softer and more patient not only
with
the world but myself and i just i'm
starting to see
things through a little kid's eyes and
not through
um my own which you know can be you know
it can be hard sometimes you've lived a
long life and now to see it through such
an innocent
pure eyes i mean things just they seem
different they
they they're more fun and innocent and
it's just been so beautiful
yeah what about justin as a dad have you
seen
little changes in him first of all oh my
gosh it's like he got
hotter when isaac was born
that's amazing i'm like
oh change that dirty diaper you are so
fine you're gonna clean up that quest
thank you it's like oh acts of service
is my
love language so it has been on fleek
it's been so
oh yeah i
it's funny i remember a few years ago
your memoir came
out and you talked a lot about your
parents
and the effect that each of them whether
negative or positive had
on on your life today and i'm just
curious what values
are important that you and justin
instill in isaac
the first thing is communication i mean
justin
and i our communication is rock solid
and so
we really are trying to keep teach isaac
how to communicate with us even though
he can't talk we're trying to we're
trying to teach him sign language it's
very difficult
we're trying it we're like eat
milk you know finish he can't speak
so he but he can use his hands so
for us it's like it's really about you
know teaching this other side of your
brain
like how to communicate and not just
so i mean we're still dealing with the
uh uh
and um kindness has been a really big
one in our house as well
whether it's between justin and i um or
with isaac it's you know it's about
being
um being kind i love that
you sort of joked about wanting to get
pregnant yesterday is i think what you
said
and i personally never like to just
straight up ask someone
what the plan is because you never know
it's it's just like a personal matter
but since you brought it up
what is i guess the hope i know
trust me i am working on it it is it is
in action as we speak
all right so it's it's maybe around the
corner
could you be
i interviewed a celebrity who came under
fire for posting
a photo of herself breastfeeding
you do it i think often and you get
crazed
for it which i think is a sign that
things are moving in a
more positive direction
um do you do you think the more we talk
about that kind of thing
it's helping in kind of removing this
weird
i don't even want to use the word stigma
because it should have never been a
stigma
no but i honestly i think the more we
post anything and the more that we put
something out into the world and
whether it's on your social media your
youtube whatever it is i think that's
the most important thing we've never had
this platform before where we can just
truly talk about things that we are
passionate about
and so to me breastfeeding um you know
whether you do it or whether you don't
do it as a mother like
it should just be normalized just like
anything else when it comes to being a
parent everybody parents differently
everybody treats their body differently
and so
to post yourself breastfeeding should be
normalized just as much as giving your
child a bottle
you and justin have been married over 10
years now
i am i am soon getting married
so i just want to know what advice would
you give me
oh my gosh well first of all
congratulations
i think first of all marry your best
friend because that's a really big deal
you want to make sure that you guys like
each other liking each other is such a
big deal
um and talking through everything there
should be nothing that
is left unsaid and justin and i always
say to each other
don't assume that i think i know that
you think i know something and vice
versa
because um i don't know everything and
you can't read my mind
so um talking about everything
communication is so key
i do have to say congrats because you
are the new face of
san tropez and as someone who i feel
like
exudes body positivity feeling
good how does a tan kind of help you
i guess elevate those things
well first of all thank you that's so
nice of you and second of all for me the
tan
isn't really about how it makes you look
but how it makes you feel
um i think that i i always kind of want
to have
this instant glow and that's exactly
what santropay
provides is a beautiful natural instant
glow
when you do think about i guess your
current beauty ideals in general what
what comes to mind for me beauty ideals
are really about being true to yourself
not erasing but enhancing
um something that has that i really just
always want is to inspire confidence
within yourself
um and and i think that
skin has always been in so really
embrace
your skin and take care of it